scp is so important because it opens
your eyes and opens your perspective to
issues and challenges and opportunities
that your company may have never
encountered i've always leveraged my
team but really understanding the power
of these outside networks that you
develop
was was a very big eye-opener for me
it is about
six to seven weeks that you take out of
your out of your life for
a whole range of education
self-reflection building relationships
that last a lifetime that then enable
you to come out and change your life in
the ways that you would like to change
it you're taking away things that are
going to be with you for the rest of
your life it's going to change your
trajectory
on how you lead teams how you think
about problems how you how you manage
through different situations
it's with you forever as executives your
time is such a precious resource
anything that you can do
that is going to save you time and save
you time month over month year over year
is invaluable so to me that's that's the
real roi of sap
[Music]